Übung 1 hüftabduktion im Stehen starten
Sie mit geschlossenen Füßen und stützen
sie die Hände seitlich am Rumpf ab falls
benötigt können Sie sich an einer
stuhlehne festhalten spannen Sie die
Gesäßmuskulatur an und heben Sie ein
Bein vom Boden ab dabei sollte das Knie
in einem 45° Winkel gebeugt sein achten
Sie hierbei auf die Aufrichtung des
Beckens Oberkörpers sowie den Schultern
öffnen Sie nun das Knie zur Seite
indem sie es aus der Körpermitte nach
außen bewegen halten Sie diese Position
für 3 Sekunden und gehen Sie dann in die
Ausgangsstellung zurück halten Sie die
Gesäßmuskulatur dabei angespannt und die
Beinachse des Standbeins stabil
wiederholen Sie diese Übung 10 bis 15
Mal auf einer Seite und wechseln Sie
dann das
Bein